(soft jazz music)
- Hi, I'm Inga.
I'm here in Hong Kong, my
hometown, for a couple of days.
Apparently the fanciest
McDonald's in the world
is right here
in the background.
It's called McDonald's Next.
They say it's amazing, and
it looks super gourmet,
so I'm super excited.
Let's go in and see just how
fancy McDonald's can get.
(classical ballroom music)
I'm here to order a
little bit of everything
at this fancy McDonald's.
Let's see how bougie we can get.
Gonna start with this bakery style bun,
100% angus beef, thick cut,
mozzarella, lettuce,
tomato, caramelized onion,
Big Mac sauce.
Truffle.
(lively jazz music)
All that good stuff.
(cash register rings)
California blend, shaved parmesan,
roasted sesame, sweet corn, crouton,
tomato, quinoa.
They have quinoa.
Chicken.
This salad's gonna be amazing.
My God.
Oh my God.
Who knew you could spend
this much money at McDonald's.
(cash register rings)
I think we a pretty,
Ooh, McCafe.
Maybe I'll get an iced latte.
Chocolate sundae waffle cone
and matcha.
A mango macaron.
I think that's all I should get.
Let's look at the total order.
274 dollars.
(cash register rings)
Let's do it.
(lively jazz music)
(gasps) Yeah!
Here we go.
Now we wait for the food to come.
(energetic swing music)
Table service.
They just gave me my salad
and then asked if I wanted
the dessert served after.
It's like being at an actual restaurant.
OK, no problem.
Thank you.
Just got the iced cappuccino
and the iced latte.
They look insanely good.
Look at this.
If you put this in a Starbucks
cup and you gave it to me,
I would have thought it was Starbucks.
It's really good.
I'm really surprised.
I think it's like freshly ground coffee.
Oh, sheet!
Premium coffee beans.
McDonald's has their own coffee beans.
That is insane.
Gonna check this salad out.
And this is what it looks like.
(soft jazz music)
The grilled chicken,
croutons, the crayfish mayo,
tomatoes, shaved
parmesan, quinoa couscous.
Gonna put this sesame dressing on.
(soft jazz music)
Yaaass.
I really like it.
Not normally a salad person,
but this salad I would totally eat.
Oh, the bacon.
The crayfish is really good.
I thought it would be like
imitation crab meat or something.
No, it's actual crayfish.
(soft jazz music)
Gee, that is amazing.
When you customize your
own salad at whole foods,
that's what it tastes like.
Everything is really fresh.
You can pick what you like.
It's amazing.
Sorry, this is really good.
Let me get another bite.
(giggles) I really like it.
I just got the burger.
It looks so good (gasps.)
(lively jazz music)
That's a huge burger.
Look at all those layers.
McDonald's fries just
stepped up their game.
And we have actual silverware.
That's not plastic.
It's metal, like you would
see at an actual restaurant.
If I told you this was from McDonald's,
you would not believe me.
We're not talking normal patties.
This is like double the
thickness of normal patties.
Let's go for it.
(lively jazz music)
You can actually see the meat in there.
Big Mac sauce and truffle sauce together.
(bomb blasts)
Mind blown.
It is so good.
It's so good!
Who would have ever thought
that McDonald's sells truffle sauce.
I think I was a little bit skeptical,
but this actually tastes really good.
I would totally order this again.
Holy shit!
Well, it still looks
like an ice cream, right?
This is the chocolate waffle cone.
The texture of this ice
cream is very much like
their normal soft serve
but the waffle cone is super buttery.
It is super nice.
I got myself a matcha parfait.
Vanilla ice cream on top,
and then I think there's chocolate bits.
(soft jazz music)
The matcha smells really good.
Oh my God.
Let's do this.
It blends together really, really well.
I can't believe that
this is from McDonald's.
Mango macaron at McDonald's.
It's not absolutely amazing,
but it's not bad.
I'm really impressed, McDonald's.
Now that we had burgers and salads,
and coffees and desserts,
I think this is the perfect way
to finish off a fancy McDonald's
meal here in Hong Kong.
Thank you, McDonald's, for showing me that
even fast food can be really fancy.
(upbeat acoustic music)